ja gut die Hinwendung noch Asien hat ja
nicht erst seit Trump begonnen
beiden damals noch Vizepräsident hat
Obama segundiert der sich von Europa ab
und nach Asien hingewendet hat sowohl
militärisch als auch
wirtschaftspolitisch was jetzt
Trump forciert hast ist diese
Konfrontation mit
China das hat beiden noch mal verschärft
Bein hat zwar einen konzilianten mit uns
mit unserer Europäern aber die
Verschärfung mit China die ist real ich
glaube da können wir übereinstimmen
beiden macht vieles sogar noch härter
man könnte sogar sagen
Trump hat gebellt beiden beißt was China
angeht und das wird Europa noch vor sehr
viel größere Schwierigkeiten stellen als
dieses Scharmützel jetzt mit Russland
und Putin da steigen wir gleich ganz
tief ein vor allem zu dem Verhältnis mit
China mich würde aber vor allem auch die
europäische Rolle interessieren und die
Rolle Deutschlands ist Deutschland nicht
mehr interessant nicht mehr wichtig aus
ihren Augen nicht mehr wichtig wir
setzen
wir haben vorher schon vom
weltministische Außenpolitik geredet
aber wollten eigentlich nicht wirklich
über aus dem Politik reden ich erinnere
mich an den Wahlkampf Armin Laschet hat
vergebens versucht Kolleginnen und
Kollegen von ihnen jetzt nicht bei Bild
sondern bei denen die das moderiert
haben Außenpolitik näher zu bringen
wollte keiner drüber reden also erst
nachdem Putin angegriffen hat sind viele
die vorher von außen Politik nur
geträumt haben in einer anderen Welt
aufgewacht wir haben jetzt verstanden
dass wir für unsere Sicherheit auch was
tun müssen dass Militär auch wichtig ist
dass NUK leare Abschreckung wichtig ist
ich glaube wir müssen uns die Frage
stellen warum hat Putin angegriffen
warum hat die Abschreckung versagt da
müssen wir selbstkritisch sagen ja wir
hier in Europa haben davon geträumt dass
wir dem Ende des äh ja der Geschichte
dem ewigen Frieden dagegen war aber nur
nach Amerika muss selbstkritisch sagen
ja wir waren schwach wir haben mit
unserer Schwäche Putin eingeladen
sie können gerne reagieren aber mich
würde auch wirklich sehr amerikanische
Blick auf Deutschland interessieren also
hier waren einige Punkte angesprochen
gerade mir dann ein bisschen in
Vergessenheit
ich nehme an weil sie scheinbar doch
orientiert sein sind sie kennen die
Hunter Geschichte FBI sie kennen die
Ciao Geschichte mit beiden
mit der mit der ganzen natives zumindest
hat
sie mich nicht aussprechen lassen
ich verstehe aus welche Richtung sie
andeuten ich habe nun mal andere
Richtung wenn sie mich aussprechen
lassen dann würde ich ihnen das
darstellen auch wenn Sie mich versuchen
natürlich aus dem Konzept zu bringen es
ist nun mal so dass die
Sicherheitsdienste CIA und so weiter und
so fort diese ganzen Geschichten mit
Putin als Putins Clowns zu den ähm Trump
über 200 Jahre dargestellt habe und
nichts aber nichts dahinter war und so
weiter also das so weit ist so viel zu
den Sicherheitsdiensten und zum
Vertrauen zu den amerikanischen sicherer
und die dürfen nicht politisiert werden
FBI CIA NSA dürfen nicht politisiert
werden die haben einen Job zu machen und
das war's aber nicht politisiert damit
die auf auf Kandidaten oder auf die
Wahlen Einfluss nehmen das ist da gebe
ich Ihnen das ist eine Krankheit gewesen
in den USA und das muss ausge das muss
sauber aufgearbeitet
in der These Deutschland hat zu wenig
getan als ich zu wenig nach vorne wartet
sich selber nicht ernst genug genommen
und setzt Außenpolitik nicht hoch genug
auf die Agenda sind sie sich vielleicht
auch in dem Punkt
nämlich das war doch der Trump der hat
gesagt er muss die zwei Prozent hier
aufführen sonst ist NATO ähm
das war der Trump der das gesagt und
jetzt plötzlich sind 100 Millionen zur
Verfügung und jetzt ist alles zu spät
und das Problem ist ein bisschen mehr
aus
wir haben schon ein bisschen was getan
aber ist zu spät sagen Sie also wir
haben nicht genug getan es muss nur
festhalten mit der Ukraine wissen sie es
wir reden hier über China und über den
anderen kritischen Bereich das kann man
mit Europa nicht vergleichen weil und
das kann ich Ihnen genau sagen warum
weil nämlich Japan und Taiwan und
Südkorea besser vorbereitet sind für
eine eventuelle Invasion der
kommunistischen China als Ukraine war
Ukraine wir haben in Europa waren wir
total eingeloggt von dem Putin was für
netter Mann er ist und was alles so
erzählt hat und noch sieben Tage von dem
Angriff
obwohl beiden schon klar gesagt hat der
hat ihn vor Nachrichten
Informationen dass diese dass das keine
Manöver ist weil sie da gezogen hat
sondern dass das Vorbereitung eines
Angriffes ist da hat man in Europa noch
gar nicht geglaubt dass das überhaupt
passiert und von da aus
natürlich Europa und da gebe ich Ihnen
auch insofern Recht muss auch hier die
Kräfte zusammensammeln und auch
verteidigungsfähig und willig sein vor
allem und das Europa vielleicht auch
wirtschaftlich eher auf dem Abstellgleis
landet das ist gleich unser großes Thema
hier nach einer ganz kurzen Pause das
hat natürlich auch was mit der
Energiekrise zu tun und da schauen wir
gleich drauf bis gleich wurden sie
abgezockt oder reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung das
kann ich Wahnsinn jetzt melden unsere
Reporter kümmern sich um Ihren Fall
kämpft für Sie